[ __ ] so I guess once this like once the
fortnight craze is over and I can't
expect it'll last forever do you have
plans for after that or what do you
think will happen after that or what are
your plans for after that's over I don't
know I mean it all depends like I think
the main the main thing they'll stop for
now from being popular is another game
and if I like it I'll play it if I don't
then I'll just post vlogs and play any
random games and just be a variety
streamer like teach like PewDiePie yeah
because I'm playing games competitively
stressful it's time-consuming yeah and
like I've been playing competitive for a
while so I don't know I don't know how
I'm not gonna do it forever obviously
yeah do you do you see yourself being
like 3540 years old doing it like plate
like cuz right now you basically have a
[ __ ] every day you're spending your
spending I don't see myself playing like
competitive like that my brain is gonna
be melted by then yeah my hyzer be fried
is that this is really bad for you to
stare the computer stare like games that
long what what's like what can happen I
don't know do you know of anything like
crazy [ __ ] happening to people from
doing that now their eyes like I've had
a few friends of mine I have like
tendonitis playing and like Oh from like
the mice and the keyboard and so yeah
you had a crazy headache in the car
today yeah I still have a dick Sophie
like [ __ ]
is that from the screen could be better
be careful dude they make like computer
glasses that you can get I like yeah I
mean the thing is the thing is like we
don't know because our parents our older
siblings and stuff they didn't have they
didn't have another kid so how do you
know like it's actually bad yeah dude
you should play safe you should get you
should have glasses just don't wear yeah
I just fried my brain you should wear
them dude you should look into getting
some glasses to protect yourself don't
melt your brain please when I'm older
and my eyes are fried and my brains
fried did though shoot some shoot some
stem cells into my brain or something
yeah
get some Bionic eyeballs I heard that
playing video games improves cognitive
function and vision like I heard that it
improves your vision and actually like
improves your cognitive skills too maybe
you know anything about that
maybe I mean I I train my my reaction my
tracking every day really yeah how do
you do that
I played training games
okay just other video games that are
just like strictly for coordination yeah
okay have you ever tried here tried
meditating no my ADHD is probably too
bad for me to be able to meditate
because there's a I've ever heard of
like like flow state you know that is
yeah when like people can like you can
meditate and like it's a they say that
when you like focus on being in the
moment or like when you focus on being
present you can people can train
themselves to access that flow state or
whatever like instant whenever they want
and they say that gamers actually
achieve that more than anybody like
gamers and like basketball players and
like Michael Jordan used to like the old
like 90s Bulls they used to do like
group meditations to like practice
getting into that flow steak because
when they're the whole team like in that
state when they're playing or whatever
it's like you're not thinking about
anything you're not thinking about like
the past the future all you're thinking
about is like you're not you know even
you know your brain is not thinking all
you're doing is like reacting to what's
happening in the core like similar to
how you like I'm sure you've experienced
that numerous times when you're just
like everything is going perfect right
like everything is going right in a game
like you can't [ __ ] up anything yeah
they call it flow State and that's they
say that meditation can help that but
what if what is you're trying to figure
out what's gonna happen in the future
moments though then you [ __ ] yourself
this one you stifle yourself and you
overthink that's when people look like
like [ __ ] up you always got the steps
ahead especially one player for tonight
yeah really
be ready for everything how so you ready
did you guys think about the future you
gotta think about what could potentially
happen more so what could potentially
okay
because that's probably the possibility
that yeah I guess it's a lot more
complicated than pac-man in that sense
because you have to like it's not just
what's happening now you got to think
about like where where you're gonna end
up and like where the other players will
be in that kind of [ __ ]